freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren bestell video und wir werden
niemals die ideen ausgehen wir haben es
heute etwas ganz besonderes überlegt und
zwar werden wir bei jeder auffindbaren
kategorie also bei ein zwei drei vier
und fünf sternen essen bestellen und ich
muss das ganze zu ordnen wir das sind
eric und ich erlebt wird gleich die
bestellungen tätigen und ich werde
meinen daumen konzentrieren und
probieren herauszufinden welches essen
das beste ist und welches das
allerschlechteste ist sehr interessant
ich muss sich auf jeden fall anstrengen
heute damit ich das ganze hoffentlich
richtig zuordnen und wer weiß vielleicht
ist ja die eine oder andere überraschung
dabei wir haben gleich fünf verschiedene
speisen und zwar wird das immer der
jeweilige bestseller sein also das ist
auch möglichst gut zu erkennen ist
schauen wir mal was das wird und hunger
habe ich auf jeden fall legen würde
haben wir meinen heutigen gegenspieler
erregt er jetzt gerichte bestellen wird
und eric wird natürlich wie immer wollen
dass ich es nicht schaffe sie nach
ordnung und ich werde die mannschaft
hoffentlich herrick sucht gerade schon
aus und ich komme gar nicht so es wird
eine komplette überraschung für mich
sein die frage ist nur ob es überhaupt
einen sterne läden gibt welche hat
glaube ich ein einziges mal einen laden
mit einer eins vor dem komma gesehen das
war als mit freddy damals bubble tea
bestellt habe oder so ich war auch
wirklich
kein einziger und zwei sternen an ein
stern gibt es wohl nicht es gibt keine
schlechten restaurants und deswegen ist
wenn ich einen stern vom komma hätte
wird ja noch mein laden zu machen
trotzdem haben wir eine auswahl an zwei
sternen okay dann fangen wir einmal zwei
sternen und genau da fangen jetzt einmal
an gerne auch den ersten laden bitte
nicht vorstellen was so
lebensmittelvergiftung anfällig ist okay
erste bestellung ist raus ich musste
noch ein paar getränke hinzufügen damit
die bestellung auch wirklich ankommt
denn mindestbestellwert war 15 euro was
ich okay finde wichtig dass du mir aber
auch gesagt hat fünf euro lieferkosten
weil das werden ja auch leute in ihre
bewertung mit einem greisen er bewertet
wir wahrscheinlich so fünf euro
lieferkosten und ich warte 70 minuten
das teilt ankommt ein stern soll
dementsprechend sind das alles ganz
wichtige informationen ich sauge sie auf
wie ein schwamm zweites restaurant drei
sternen das ding es gibt bestimmt mal so
kleine überraschungen
dieser laden nur drei sternen so die man
kennt die eigentlich gut sind ja in
sicherheit in sicherheit aber ich werde
wirklich das gesamtkonzept müssen
dann schauen wir mal
ein weiterer laden dem ich jetzt
ausgewählt habe er hat selbst gerade
gesehen hab so angst zu viel sind
zweite bestellung drei sterne ich glaube
ich hab was cooles ausgewählt hoffe es
zumindest gewinns gleichkommt ich sehe
es auch auf zum nächsten restaurant ab
geht's zum nächsten oder und während
ähnliche was schönes für uns besteht
erzähle ich euch ein bisschen was zu ihr
könnt nämlich mit die gräber über 1800
partnershops jeden tag online spaß da
gibt es zum beispiel booking wenn ein
reisebuch es aus wenn ihr klamotten
geschockt oder eben die verhandlungen ja
ich weiß der größten essen bestellen
wird das prinzip wie das ganze
funktioniert ist ein klassisches win win
prinzip egal erhält für eure bestellung
eine vermittlungsprovision und gibt
diese zum großteil an euch weiter so
verdient ein bisschen was und ihr kriegt
bares geld egal ist für dich komplett
kostenlos und es gibt stetig gutscheine
die mit dem cashback kombinierbar sind
wir können über den browser oder in der
app die shops aussuchen kommt damit
einen klick auf die webseiten die
erkennt und könnt wie gewohnt einkaufen
außerdem könnt ihr euch den cashback
männer als browser erweiterung
installieren derzeit ich dann immer an
wenn ihr irgendwo sparen können
einen seite befindet und aktiviert für
euch automatisch das cashback wenn ihr
übrigens eure freude zu egal wäre ich
wahrscheinlich den eric hier nach dem
video dann kriegt ihr fünf euro für jede
anwendung von einem freund und zehn
prozent von seinem cashback bei jedem
einkauf sobald ihr 20 euro an cash back
gesammelt habt könnt ihr es euch einfach
auszahlen lassen kriegt aber zehn euro
wenn ich über meinen link registriert
alles um in der video beschreibung würde
sagen ganze steht nichts mehr im weg wie
sieht's aus mit dem restaurant hast du
das gefunden ich habe etwas gefunden was
es wird versucht ja auch die ganze zeit
so ein bisschen auch abwechslung
einzubringen deswegen wir bestellen ist
es hat 99 cent lieferkosten schon mal
gut bemerken fünf euro an hatte zwei
euro fünfzig sind aber 99 cent das
spielt alles initiatoren ihr habt
gesehen muss ich bestellt habe wir
kommen zum nächsten restaurant fünf
sterne restaurants und hier haben wir
wirklich eine große auswahl wie viele
gibt es lass mich raten ich würde sagen
unter 5 unser bündnis richtig genauer
sagt ja ja ich weiß aber herrlich nicht
mehr am lieferkosten von fünf euro 99
und einen mindestbestellwert von 15 euro
also schon mal ein und 20 euro die wir
bestehen müssen der laden muss der
kasten 13 5 sternen weil leute das
bezahlt und trotzdem so gut wie nicht
nur 12 bewertung bringt den ferrari oder
rasse
stellungen sind ernst gespannt ob es dir
schmecken wird ob die meine auswahl
gefällt wie gut sie dir gefällt und ob
du auch die sterne zu ordnen kannst das
denken sich fall hier gleich vom stuhl
deshalb ich glaube ich hätte alles mögen
aber schon sehr gespannt darauf was du
gestellt hat und ob ich schaffe es
zuzuhören
ihr seht jetzt schon mal eingeblendet
wie viele sterne das ganze hat max weiß
es noch nicht und er kriegt jetzt die
erste bestellung von mir vor die nase
gesetzt viel spaß ich sehe zwar logisch
aber ihr sind dementsprechend ist es
eindeutig was das ganze ist ich mir auf
jeden fall froh dass dies gerade vor mir
stehen habe aber ich verstehe auch herum
rx gewählt hat wird mir mal rein was das
überhaupt ist also das hat ja jetzt erst
mal nichts damit zu tun wie das ganze
bewertet sein wird ein bürger ist drin
und schauen wir mal was es für einen
burger ist double cheeseburger broadway
wahrscheinlich eine sache mit der man
auf jeden fall nichts falsch macht und
jetzt müssen wir aber auch schon in die
analyse einsteigen wäre das nicht liebt
was denkt er sich wenn er diesen
bürgerhaus packt so werde ich weiß wie
es sein für das sieht schon so ein
bisschen verrutscht aus und sohn etwas
mal rein reißen
hast du den konfiguriert werden dass sie
keine soßen drauf gar kein ketchup
also an und für sich das super
seitenschiff bürger ohne soße mit
champignons
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
eigentlich für mich etwas mit einer vier
vor dem komma viernheim sowas weil es
halt einfach so du weißt was du bekommst
das ist auch was man bekommen wird also
das ist so ein feiner halt einfach so
wie sehen das aber alle leute das ist
die frage nicht mehr stellen müsse für
mich ist das aber selbst mit einer 4
erfolg sage ich vier sterne für den vfb
erste nummer zwei gerade hast du schon
mal eine bewertung abgegeben ob das
richtig ist sehen wir ja noch ihr wisst
schon die zuschauer ist
du hast ja nur sachen besteht ich kenne
mangelt oder lukas podolski
das meint das macht natürlich den
probiert auch extrem strand ein manga
lukas podolski
er kam mit der ersten bestellung amt ist
jetzt schon relativ abgekühlt aber ich
glaube das ist halt mein verschulden wie
schmeckt erde weil das ist ja auch sehr
standort
er schmeckt für mich wie jeder andere
mangel poldi den achten also letzter
vielen leuten schmeckt er bestimmt sehr
sehr gut mir schmeckt ja auch nicht
schlecht die gesagt nicht meine erste
wahl wenn wir bei dem jahr war auch
sicher dass es weder 5 noch zwei sterne
hat im kreis und holly ist für mich ein
ich so auf einer ebene würde ich sagen
so von der klasse her das macht es nicht
unbedingt leicht für mich muss halt
sagen poldi natürlich absoluter
sympathieträger in köln deshalb würde
ich jetzt aus dem fall auch sagen dass
das vielleicht noch höher ein geordnetes
als fünf sterne kann einfach nicht sein
dafür ist ein döner auch kein so gutes
liefer produkt sowie ein döner kommt nie
so geil angeliefert werden halt machen
laden ist ich bin ja aber eigentlich
auch sicher das ist kein drei stellen
hat ich glaube tatsächlich dass der
mangel döner vier sterne hat das heißt
im umkehrschluss heißen würde das 5 3
hat das auch nicht so sinnvoll ist aber
es macht mehr sinn für mich ich
korrigiere mangold 45 13 auf zum
nächsten restaurant neues restaurant
neues glück wir haben eine weitere
lieferando tüte
okay
funktionen muss ich jetzt einmal ganz
kurz dazu sagen weil ich da auch ein
bisschen verwundert war hast du etwa
eine sache gestellt die ich noch nicht
kenne
unglaublich eine position besser pence
auf dem zettel dran ist muss schmecken
das sieht eigentlich so sehr schön aus
also es ist so als wäre das von so einem
food truck börse
ist das so ein panin oder wie bisschen
lieblos aus aber ich meine es ist ja
auch nicht dafür gemacht auch zu knappen
hammond schießt und ladies bisschen
eigenartig aber das brot an und für sich
ist ein schönes fettiges italienische
ciabatta teil portion
das ist krank weißt du was mich schon
was mich direkt vorweg irritiert das ist
für mich auch wieder nicht nach zwei
oder fünf sternen aussieht aber ich habe
jetzt mein mittelfeld schon vergeben
quasi ich mache mal die soße sagt das
irritiert mich auch allein schon dass
ich so nicht dem namen kenne vom
restaurant das ist es sieht aber da wird
es mir zustimmen nicht so liebevoll auf
aber das ist wiederum smart dass die die
soße so eine zeit liefern weiß halt
sonst durchweicht und so kann ich glaub
ich muss ich muss den geschmack
überzeugen oder nicht überzeugen lassen
das ist nicht 5 das ist auf jeden fall
nicht die fünfte eine sache bei so kann
es eigentlich nicht sein weil es brot so
sehr tui ist ganz ist ein bisschen
trocken es hat auf jeden fall nicht so
ein flash ich finde 5 mussten flash
haben so das hat so charakter dass man
so sagt worauf wie krass war das gerade
es schmeckt auch generell einfach nicht
noch so wahnsinnig viel
ich hatte gerade noch an euch das ding
ist könnte mir vorstellen dass das so
ein laden ist erst von vielen leuten so
ein guilty pleasure dort die bestellen
hat abends auf der couch gucken
irgendwie einen schönen serien filme
schauen sie sich dieses drei meter
center schreien rund feiern das übel
weil man viel für sein geld bekommt kann
ich mir vorstellen das ist halt nicht so
gut wie mangel aber es ist auch nichts
mit zwei sternen finde dafür ist es zu
viel so es war schön verpackt eine große
portionsgröße es ist von den rohstoffen
nicht verkehrt so also ja man sieht hier
auch für die untere seite wurde sie
bislang gekostet die oberseite nicht ich
werde auch sagen müssen dass es mit zwei
ist aber ich meine wenn du es auch mit
10 8 gerechnet würde ich würde nicht
sagen es hat vier von zehn verdienen ja
so eine starke 5 und 10 da kommt auch
schon das nächste deshalb sage ich das
hier ist mein zwei sterne restaurant und
jetzt sehe ich mich entweder bestätigt
oder ich bin da fragt mein ganzes leben
bei der nächsten bestellung augen zu ich
gucke aber zu kümmern wenn ich richtig
liege wisse jetzt meine 55 kommen aber
sehen wir sind ob das sehen das kann
jetzt alles durcheinander werden
ich fühl schon was
ich muss nicht probieren das waren hole
ich habe euch schon mal im video nämlich
mal eine bestell favoriten gezeigt der
bariton von bruder erzählt chilis bot es
gibt wirklich so ganz viele verschiedene
ausgefallene chilis und wir haben das
als wir das entdecken dave und ich zwei
wochen lang jeden tag bestellt aber das
heißt ja nicht dass ich weiß aber auch
das ist ihre lieb also ich habe ja in
letzter zeit selten die verhandlung
gestellt aber es hat auch auf anderen
die fabs top-bewertung ich muss es
original nicht probiert aber es ist
schon wieder was das ich kenne bei drei
von vier restaurants jetzt geld sparen
können rx einfach sagen können hier
haben wir zum foto nur weil es bei walt
gut bewertet das heißt es ja nichts es
ist halt krass schmeckt das in der 55
schmeckt das ich liebte zeit wäre es
würde mich auch wundern wenn du es nicht
für dich selbst bestellt hättest weil du
gleich den rest essen willst du kleiner
wie gesagt ja es ist nicht mehr als die
eine gabel branchen ist das meine 55
soweit das ist das perfekte
lieferservice orgi burger verklebt so
ein bisschen wird eingedellt das andere
war einfach komisch das hier ist mit 55
das hat eine 5 und 5 beim irakkrieg 25
und 55 geist für mich vier einheit
glaube meine erste eindruck war jedes
mal nicht ganz verkehrt genießt das
jetzt und dann sortiere ich mich noch
mal ein bisschen verteilt die sterne
aber ich glaube ich hat das heute gut
gemacht ich habe meine geschmacksnerven
auf die probe gestellt meine
gesellschafts kenntnis ebenso ein stern
hatten werden zwei sterne restaurant
muss das mit dem quadratmeter sandwich
gewesen sein mich weil ich finde dass es
nur zwei ställe verdient hat ich würde
ihnen wahrscheinlich drei sterne geben
dreieinhalb es war etwas teuer und zwar
komisch ist es sich nicht so gut wären
auf dem mit drei sternen sich fünf geist
weil es halt einfach so vermischen
verteilt ist und so fühlst dich danach
scheiße aber du musst wissen das ist was
du bestellst bei facebook auf jeden
bürger der durchaus noch und du musst
das wollen deshalb ist es für mich
viereinhalb aber drei sternen und nicht
mehr relativ sicher dementsprechend
bleiben nur noch vier sterne übrig für
manga weil meine 515 safe an bambule ich
würde mich selbst belügen sonst uns bin
mir unsicher 5 und 5 ist und ich finde
ja auch ziemlich sicher dass ich alles
richtig hell wird jetzt die auflösung
was natürlich nicht alles richtig nein
nein das ist falsch zwei sterne manga
ich fand es nicht kraft aber das ist
halt ein mandat gehabt deswegen halte
ich dieses standortbezogene auch
vielleicht ist dieser standort auch
einfach gerade vielleicht abends bei
stoßzeiten wirklich dafür prädestiniert
ist ihre bestellungen nicht kommen man
kennt es ja ich stehe für mein geld das
ist krass das hätte ich echt nicht
gedacht drei sterne five guys warst du
richtig vier sterne dieses baguette
4,6 oder so aber das ist den beliebten
gerichten gewesen hörte sagt ganz
präzise hat sich bewahrheitet wovon an
den laden ich habe ja auch gesagt zwei
der nacht und unfair raster ich hätte es
nicht leid ich war mir wirklich sicher
ich hätte alles recht für einsteiger
natürlich beim bruder nicht sogar reden
leute man kann so viel spaß beim islam
man kann aber auch so viel spaß
drumherum haben wieder irgendeine
rückflüge werden um auf kreative art und
weise essen wird spaßig hatte auf jeden
fall spaß vielleicht finden wir eines
tages in ein sternerestaurant drehen
noch ein paar zwei falls ja was er sonst
wissen wenn ihr das sehen wollt wir sind
es beim nächsten video wieder bis dahin
und dankeschön noch mal nicht